moi je veux juste et épanouie dans mon
travail je veux juste et épanouie c'est
à peu près tout ce qui m'intéresse
d'abord envoyé beaucoup de cv oui comme
un 50 environ
oui environ et peu d'offres peu d'offres
il y en a quand même eu dans ma région
dans les collectivités y en a quand même
mais ses 10 ans d'expérience dans
souvent et puis dans les collectivités
il embauche de plus en plus de
contractuels mais il faut les concours
et moi ça ne m'intéresse pas forcément
passer des concours puisque là ça veut
dire oui on m'a aussi dit mais tu
pourrais faire deux ans de plus cette
avocate ou bien un an + et les concours
sauf que ça veut encore dire deux ans à
étudier donc qu'ils veulent financer ces
pas pôle emploi là j'ai eu 1 500 euros
de pôle emploi
clairement c'est pas avec 500 euros
qu'on va loin donc j'ai été obligé
d'accepter des jobs qui me plaisait pas
pour vivre mais du coup si on travaille
à temps plein c'est compliqué en
travaillant à temps plein d'avoir du
temps disponible pour les candidatures
je pense que vous qui avez enfin vous
savez que ça prend du temps d'envoyer
des cv c'est un cercle vicieux voit la
patte en a pas envie de faire un job
alimentaire parce que voilà on veut
faire quelque chose en anglais bien sûr
pas nous lâcher c'est bien si on ne peut
pas aussi se permettre de refuser
quelque chose voilà et autre point
important aussi je me suis endetté comme
comme toi parce que j'ai travaillé
jusqu'à ma troisième année de droit à un
moment donné je n'arrivais plus j'avais
des bourses de l'état
donc ça je ne crache pas dessus ça veut
dire oui j'ai redoublé ma troisième
année parce que je m'entraîne à 9 heures
par semaine je faisais du sport assez
haut niveau jeu
faisait de la restauration 15 heures par
semaine du ménage dans les études et un
moment donné je me suis dit soit
j'arrête mes études
soit il j'ai croisé la route d'un
banquier que je remercie encore parce
que je faisais des ménages dans sa
banque
on a parlé du prêt étudiant j'ai tenté
ce prêt étudiant
mais là le clou du spectacle ma mère
étant au smic et en toute seule avec
trois enfants elle n'était pas assez
solvable pour est de se former caution
pour ce prélat donc déjà là il ya un
gros souci c'est comme un prêt étudiant
pour aider les étudiants
mais si on n'a pas des coups alors parce
que le serbe banquiers connaissait ma
situation savais que c'était quelqu'un
de motivé il s'était rendu au troisième
et des droits et ses devoirs bérénice à
2 heures
voilà donc il a il a poussé le il a
poussé le truc et j'ai eu ce prêtre
serait plus tard c'est elle qui me
prendra de l'argent exactement d'un en
attendant là c'est plutôt lui qui me
prêtent encore ils sont chauds dans le
rouge etc
les bons comptes il en soit du coup moi
moi je suis pas là pour vous qu'on
trouve des solutions fin je me sens
alors je vais vous dire vous savez qui
est votre mentor non abbas et ses
incroyables pour vous ce soir parce que
celle qui va être votre mentor et les
ans vous c'est la ministre
d'accord
non c'est ce qu'a coûté le ministère de
l'environnement se disant patients ça me
choque je connais un petit peu
elle connaît bien le nom mais vous allez
être son mentor ou vous avez un mentor
pour lui voilà toi tu as et moi des
moutons et bérénice moi je trouve que
vous avez un super parcours et en plus
vous avez de l'énergie les gens d'y
aller dans des dans des domaines que je
connais bien à l'urbanisme et
l'environnement
donc je pense que c'est bien qu'on se
revoie puis on va trouver des solutions
elle va trouver des solutions pour vous
et si la mini se trouve pas de solution
pour vous là ça va mal